Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and here we've got a leap of faith!
HAHHHHHHHHHHHH
THATHATHEEREE
We made it! Okay.
Ah, shit!
What did that do to us?
Why did we do that?
Aahhh! Gah-Fuck.
God dammit I don't know--
Wha-
This is not how I wanted to start this episode.
I wanted to go to another level
that I'd be able to actually solve
That would be nice.
*with accent* Is there un secret?
Oh, God, there's no comments either. Oh! Thank--
No...
NOOOOOOO!
It's a little douchey, admittedly.
But that's okay.
So am I.
Hup! Thank you
Heh!
*terrified screams turning into relieved laughter*
You ain't gonna beat me that easy, bitch! Yeaaah!
Okay!
Now we're going somewhere.
I don't know where but we've got a 1-Up man and that's better than the--
Oh, god, hello giant
DILDOS
Where am I going, where am I going, where am I going, I don't know I hope it's not lava--
Oh, God, it's lava!
*death scream*
OOPSIES!
Ohhhhh God. Hello!
Nice to meet you.
By the way, hi guys.
How you doin'?
That last episode...
was a bitch...
A very-
POOOOOOOR showi- aha!
It's tricksies.
So it's over here, huh?
They thought they could trick me...
It was a bit of a poor showing
and, uh
I felt bad for giving up.
I really did try that
I-I tried it for a...
GOOOOood
long
amount of time. but...
I just could not
get it
IDOWAH- I DIDN'T WAAANT THAT!
Ah, there was no other way to get it besides that
OO
OO (2x)
GIVE
give to- oookay
neve- you know what?
FORGET YOU
IIIIIII GOT IT
OOHHH
*pound chest* It makes my ego feel
soooo much
better.
Where is that gonna send me?
Doing
Doing?
Nowhere? I thought that was gonna like
Bounce me up
Adjeh...
Just the sad way that he crouches
but I got three 1-mans
and I beat another level,
which is better than I can say for the last one.
I could've beaten it, but it just-
I-I couldn't see what the answer was!
There was no answer!
Man, I should've taken a bathroom break in between this last episode and this one.
Damn, I gotta go to the bathroom!
Okay, but it's fine.
It's fine, and it's fine.
Oh, boy.
The pulsating darkness is entering my brain, but at least it's given me a 1-man.
Let's do this, bitch!
See what kind of ship of terrors you- Oh!
Oh, is it a boss fight?
Ooooh I think it just might be a boss fight.
Boink! He's gone.
'Kay that's one d- ohhhh
Frick, me!
Holy crap.
Ahhh!
Aaahh!
OH GOD!
Didn't mean it. Didn't mean it.
Sorry! Sorry, buddy.
Boink
Ah-- Ooo!
Don't even think about i-
AAAAAAAH HADYOU!
I HAD YOU!
Okay,
so, it's fine, it's just a boss fight.
Which is totally fine!
I'm good with a boss fight,
I'm good in entering an enemy airship and--
--fuck!--
--roasting my taint on an open fire.
Anyway, I'm good in entering an airship
and then destroying everybody within who's trying to live their peaceful lives.
While I just ruin everything, literally.
Okay.
And somehow, I don't know how,
they've got fire shooting out of the bottom of an airship.
But when I usually think of a wooden airship...
I u- my first step would not to be to have the fire shooting up from everywhere.
Just-
Just my two cents on the matter.
Hey!
Aw, come o- What?
What? Excuse me, dickhole!
How bout-
You, you wan, you wanna run that by me again?
Bitch? You wanna ru- *laughing*
That was like the silliest way I've ever said bitch
BITCH, you wanna run by me again
I'm a real tough guy
Huh? You wanna mess with me?
Oh fireball!
Ain't gonna get me
I am too good for this
Screw you!
Okay, so the secret was to get on this platform
Cuz' otherwise I am just gonna get roasted, BOINK!
There we go.
Okay
So now stay away from all of de fire
Stupid de fire
Goodbye
Okay, you want to play?
BOINK!
Oh shit I forgot!
Okay
Hmpf
Boink
Okay, easy enough, and oh..
shit, ah god dammit
God dammit
Ah piss!
Ah piss! There we go..
Give! Give to me! Thank you... okay
So now when we got this
We'll be able to continue our merciless murdering
of everybody
with the checkpoint...and a what ever the hell is in here..
It was exactly the same as before. Okay!
So now we're continuing on to the boss - oh hello!
Do I shoot these at you?
I don't know.
You're giving..
You're not giving me a lot of space there big boy!
I am a..I am just gonna keep running
Oh god no!
AH!
AHHH!
OOOOOH, WHOA WHOA WHOOOOOOOOOOOOOA
Look who's making it
I should have made that..agh..
FAck
Oh god..
AHG My taint on an open ghost...
Let's try this again bitch....WHOA
Ahh F~ck you..
I got this
augh Stupid hammer throwing asshole
Oh god why
Woooo...
I'm glad that stopped!
That was- That was about to end very poorly for me
ok
No need to rush even though Bowser is now shooting very large fireballs
In my gen- f~ck..
Oh god
Oh no!!
Oh god how did this happen? I don't know how did this happened
I don't know
But it's ok
oh god oohh ohhh
I am being cornered!
Why didnt i jump onto that thing!
AAAAAHH!!AAAHHHHHH   *stuttering*    Oh F~ck!!
AAAAABABAAAAAAABA~~~~~!!
I blame the game..I blame the controller...
I blame the gam- oh f
ah god damnit
Now I gotta get through here... with experteeze
Malteeze
oh gowd
no nO NO NO NO NONE OF THAT NONE OF THAT
OOOOOH NONE OF THAT
NONE OF THAT
okay...
man thats the second time that i've- *huff*
I've gotten the good graces of not being roasted alive
by rampant bombs
stop stop stop stop stop
HERES MY RIDE
oh gAWD OH FUCK
Okay this is fine, im okay with this...
AH
right into the fire! I should just hurry
I should just-
ya know once I get through that second
one I should just hurry
I deserve that-
oo, NOOOO!
Not right there!
AH hes such a-
dickbag!
about pulling it AUGHGGH
COME ON!
STOP
THAT
YOU DIDNT DO THAT LAST TIME!!
YOU'RE SUCH A PRICKKKK
OOOOOOOOHH GOD!
Ohhhhhkay...
oookay
okay its fine
its fine x2
gotta hurry, gotta hurry
gotta make it through before the-
before the time runs out and the time is actuly the shape of a
BIG
FIRE BALLLSSS
MADE IT!
MADE I- AWW F-CK
WHY
NO
DONT DO THIS
TO MEEEE
AHHHH I DONT WANNA DIEEEE
I CAN- MADE!!
YES! Check point! I got it!
er- I got a check point awhile ago
AWW FAAUUUCK
ahahaooo
ho ho ho
*very matter of factly* dick
It's a bit prickish, it has a, it has a hint of prick,
Hint of prickishness
Ok, so don't go inmediately...
now go...
AWWWWWWWWW
'kay gimme this
I'm ready
*Mark warbles*
Where am i goin where am i going? (x5)
where am I where, where, where am I??
oh I get it
Just look at the eyes of death
staring from the bottom of the screen
Wait what-?
Is this- is this right?
I  believe I was supposed to go under this ship. No?
That was not it... okay
Weird
OOOHH
That make- ahhh
okay ahh -
alright.
I did not know
I should've assumed
but I did not know...
So now we're gunna have a literal airship battle-
Okay! Bring it on
bitch!
Who's shooting fireballs?!
oo hello
Who's shooting 'em?
Oh you? Eh, you ain't nobody, you ain't nobody.
Bitch.
Whoa. Okay,
so I need to get that.
Aw fuck
Okay so I got - I have to -
Why's this suck a prick?
Here we go that guys down- oh
getting cornered (x3)
This is dangerous.
Okay, you know what
*with increasing intensity* Oh God (x5)
Why?
WHY?
WHYY?
WHYYYY?
AHHHHHH!!!
AHHHHahahaha
*strained laughter*
*says singing-like* I want out, I want out, I want out, I want out~
Oh, God! I have to get the P
Ok. I'm assuming the laughing means that he's invincible
Cuz' I've been hittin' him quite a bit
Ok.
Got it (x6)
Gettin' down (x5)
Ok I'm out
I'm out, baby
I'm out
I'm out, ok
Down
I'm out
Say I won.
I WON!
I WON BABY!
YEAH!
I DIDN'T GET THE 1-UPs
FUUUUUU- DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS GOING TO BE THEEERE~
Alright
Oh! That was an endeavor.
That was an endeavor, ladies and gentlemen out there,
but I'm halfway through
and halfway through is better then no way through
so
Oh, man!
I'm going to take a look at one more and I'm going to try to do one more
I'm trying to accomplish at least three of these per episode or else it is going to take forever.
So let's do this
YES!
I LOVE YOU!
YOU GAVE ME TH-ahhhhh fuck
*laughs/giggles* never mind, I was- Hehehahaha
Love turned to hate and disdain almost immediately
Okay, but I got this
Jus-
Hevif
*In high-pitched voice* ehhh
*In high-pitched voice* ehhhhh
ehh- aww fuuuck
nugh
nughhh
Okay
Cool
Does anything happen with that?
oh, just death was going to await me
boink
Well this ain't good
Thank you?
I was going to be lost
*noise of relief*
I wonder if I could have just carried on going through there
Wha- fuahhhh- Why are you- You cou- You can't put coins here then tell me
God dammit!
You can't put coins there that tricks me into going-
Hurr
Yur
Yoourr
Yarrr
Brooo-WHAAT!
I beg to differ!
Boink
Boink, okay
Everything is "A" okay
We
are
fine
and
I
love butts.
Just wanted to throw that out there.
Okay. So now it's not going to be a prick, right?
nope
I was just supposed to fall down
Who da knowned it?
Who da thunked it?
Oh, boy...
hap
Boink
Oh, boy (x3)
Thank you
Which one of these
Is the right answer?
None of them?
Good!
Oh! Okay. I was about to jump off!
That would have been bad
Alright. Where do you lead?
I don't know where this is
but, okay
Hello
Ugaahhhhhh
Okay (x4)
Oh. Am I supposed to wait until he-
Oh, crap! (x2)
OW
Okay, so I just need to get-
man this is going to take forever if that's what I gotta wait for
Woahhh!! Hey! Now
You're an all star
get your game on
go play
Can I get another one of those?
*in some kind of accent* Can you dispense another one of the feathers?
Hey please, thank you.
THANK YOU
Cuz' I gotta clear em' out or else-
it's going to take him forever to get through it all.
AHHH! COME ON!
Bag of ass
Uhh... I already know
I-I know, I know, I know I'm fighting a boss. I'm-I'm well aware
I-I was
Did he die?
No he did not die which means tha-
Oh!
*in a high-pitched voice* Ahhhhh
*in a high-pitched voice* I"M GOING AROUND FUCK YOU
YES!
OK! That's another level down, we did it!
Ohhh... poor Bowser giving me the doe-eyes- FUCK YOU!
I DON'T GIVE A FACK
*with a slight lisp* YOU FUCK YOURSELF
But not you guys, so thank you everybody so much for watching
I'll get to the rest of this in another episode
But wish me luck cuz' I'm still going strong,
I'm on target to get to the end of this
in the right time and I made a world record there, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always...
I will see you...
In the next video! Buh-bye!
[Outro Music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]